trois ans après sa première édition la
biennale d'architecturé du paysage
revient à versailles cette année le
thème est consacré au lien entre la
terre et les villes avec un fort accent
sur le développement durable à l'heure
où les ressources terrestres se
raréfient et le climat se dérègle les
architectes se mobilisent et innove on a
choisi de construire l'exposition en
trois temps un temps de monstration
cette monumentale de ressources qui est
derrière nous qu'il fait la part belle à
toutes les ressources du sous-sol et du
sol mais aussi de l'atmosphère delà de
la région une deuxième séquence de
témoignages de pratique on a invité des
architectes du monde entier à nous
montrer ce qu'ils font avec ces matières
et les nouvelles architectures qui sont
en train d'inventer pour répondre à
l'urgence climatique et puis un
troisième grand temps qui sera une
appropriation proposé aux étudiants et
au public de ces mêmes sujets avec des
workshops pour construire en terre qu'on
se rend pas fou ça pendant les deux mois
de la biennale ce qu'on trouve je pense
très très enrichissant c'est la
diversité des approches de cette même
question mais qui converge avec vers
cette même volonté de trouver des
nouvelles manières d de répondre au
changement climatique et à ses enjeux
environnementaux
au total la bap regroupe neuf
expositions cette année elle s'ouvre
également sur le monde avec la présence
des trois lauréats du prix de l'
architecture soutenable mexique jordanie
thaïlande présentent ainsi trois
pavillons c'est une grande grande
honneur d'être invité par valérie
pécresse avec carte blanche elle a dit
amen mois le monde à versailles
aujourd'hui en europe on a des grandes
recherches en termes de nouveaux
matérialité recyclage biosourcés comme
la cellulose la terre pulvérisé tous
types de fibres qui on cherche de
réutiliser dans nos processus de
construction dans le nouveau monde on a
beaucoup moins des moyens des
développements et les recherches c'est
une fierté à deux titres parce que je
crois mal je pense que c'est maintenant
le plus grand événement le plus grand le
plus grand événement festif en
architecture en france est très
clairement et aussi parce que c'est une
biennale qui est en train de s'ancrer
dans le débat ce développement durable
c'est à dire qui est en train d'en créer
le fait que ça concerne des architectes
les architectes sont partie prenante de
la l'adaptation au réchauffement parce
qu'il s'agit mais plus lutter contre de
l'adaptation au réchauffement climatique
ils ont leur mot à dire cette seconde
édition de la bap se tiendra jusqu'au 13
juillet tout du long les visiteurs
pourront assister à des débats des
ateliers des conférences ou encore des
spectacles